an up-and-coming movie star spicy plays
the lead in supermoto which recently
premiered at the Berlin Film Festival
it's the story of Joe who loves action
films and dreams of being a superhero
she's terminally ill and has come home
from the hospital to die her sister
tries to keep her spirits up manzanita
to power cycle the whole village plays
along they all stop in their tracks
Joe's mission is to catch a thief
jess is down
[Music]
and the fantasy is not the point it's
the fact that she found heroism inside
of her and inspired a whole village to
do something everyone has a hero living
inside of them who they just need to
discover the message may be universal
but the story is set in a village in
Kenya the film was shot near Nairobi and
the dialogue is in Swahili there's
plenty of local color and specific
cultural references films from Africa
rarely find large audiences outside the
continent did you know that African
cinema as its unique style
very different from from what the West
will do and from the environment to the
language culture to the lifestyle of the
people to the dress culture and into
every order you know spices we put to
make our films and so that's what we're
trying to show to the world African
filmmakers come to international film
festivals to present their work and make
contacts like here at the Berlin ala at
the same time many of them don't want to
replicate conventional Western
filmmaking but create alternative
visions I would love to see more African
films made by Africans I think the vast
majority of African forms that go into
the mainstream circuit are actually made
by Europeans written by Europeans they
usually have a white Savior somewhere in
them and we've made it our mission to
try and change that
the villagers make Joe's last wish come
true to make a film and star in it
before she dies the film industry is in
its infancy in many African countries
for some years now filmmakers in Africa
have received support from the German
Economic Cooperation and Development
Ministry and the DW Academy it offers
workshops for directors screenwriters
camera operators and producers more than
a thousand people from 18 countries have
taken part so far including members of
the team that made simple modo its
country was so strongly to raising the
general skill set level of chin and flu
makers because what it does is that it
gives us an opportunity to work on a
much bigger production than would
ordinarily be able to because we have a
bigger crew or pickup budget a pick a
story a longer story and that in itself
trains us to be able to handle bigger
projects
the German Kenyan film was co-produced
by the company founded by German
director Tom takfir to promote African
filmmaking takfir says the spread of
mobile internet and streaming services
will eventually offer great new
opportunities we need to really support
that the market inside the continent
that gets a better structure people are
actually ready to pay for watching a
great film especially if it's their own
it is not that much money and there's so
many people you know I mean imagine even
if it's just ten cents that you pay but
you've got ten percent of East Africa
paying ten cents to watch a movie it's
insanely economically useful African
filmmakers may want to grow the industry
at home but what the young star of
supermoto wants is to head further
afield